here with reaction to this and also big
news from the Second Circuit Court today
we have the president Trump's counsel
Jay Sekulow also the chief counsel
American Center for Law and Justice sir
your reaction to this on the court
ruling I think look they're now talking
about a second whistleblower and my
statement on that is so what we've
already released a transcript so does
this is it really relevant what some
other person who may or may not have
heard the conversation thought about it
the transcript has been released it is
out there in the public so again you
know what they couldn't get Russia they
couldn't get obstruction then it was
quid pro quo with Ukraine then there was
a transcript that showed no quid pro quo
then it was a cover up except there was
no cover up because the transcript was
released then it was the whistleblower
and what the whistleblower do the
whistleblower said well no first hand
now it's for most of it and then didn't
bother to tell the inspector general
that the individual was in conversations
with Adam Schiff because of course Adam
Schiff said nobody none of us had any
conversations with the whistleblower
which ended up of course not being true
so now that we have a second
whistleblower again the transcript out
it speaks for itself it is not an
impeachable offense period now number
two US Court of Appeals for the Second
Circuit today recognized I want to read
the I like reading the exact words of
the order the cases Donald J Trump
plaintiff appellant versus Cyrus Vance
who's the district attorney for the
county of New York we filed a motion
seeking an order temporary staying the
enforcement of a subpoena that was given
to the president's accountants what do
they want tax returns what do they want
in California tax returns what the court
in California say no tax returns that's
not part of the qualifications for
office the House of Representatives
basically extending their investigation
through a local DA the words of the
subpoena verbatim the words of the House
subpoenas verbatim then what happens we
go to the Second Circuit Court of
Appeals and they issue this order it is
hereby ordered that a temporary
administrative stay is granted pending
expedited review by a panel of the court
a scheduling order will issue in the
ordinary course the court also said
because of the unique issues raised by
this appeal those the unique issues
Shawn are the is really at the heart of
it is the Constitution of the United
States and
I'm wearing my hat is the president's
lawyers chief counsel of the American
Center for Law and Justice you have to
protect the Constitution that doesn't
just protect a president that protects
all of us AJ it's a post constitutional
America the great one Mark Levin said it
I mean they want to stack the courts
they want to get rid of the Electoral
College and for three years no evidence
of anything and same Liars same
conspiracy theorists or the same thing
that we've had for three years not what
industry you know showing what they've
done is they've tried to weaponize the
execution of the Constitution the
president's exercising his authority
under Article two they're trying to make
that some kind of inappropriate act they
weaponizing the Constitution here's the
good news we're winning in court we won
in California last week we got the stay
today I'm confident we win in the end
I think this impeachment inquiry
whatever they want to call it goes
nowhere
call the vote call the roll
I want them all to vote I was not doing
it they're not doing it this week or
next I don't believe it
I like they're gonna do it I hope they
do do it I dare them do it American
people are fed up with what they've done
to this country nothing they're sick of
it they see this for what it is all
right Jay Sekulow thank you